so we have had this statement literally
in the last few minutes which says
following further evaluation this
morning the queen's doctors
are concerned for her majesty's health
and have recommended that she remain
under medical supervision the queen
remains comfortable
and at balmoral so i think it's worth
reading through that again they have
said that following further evaluation
this morning the queen's doctors are
concerned about her majesty's health and
have recommended that she remain under
medical supervision the queen remains
comfortable and at balmoral
now i also understand that her immediate
family members have been informed that
the doctors have made this decision that
they have given the queen this advice
i also understand that there has been
some speculation that there may well
have been some kind of a fall the queen
may have
fallen but
i understand that is that is incorrect
and
also i think
they are very keen that there is no
further speculation
of course there undoubtedly is going to
be concern about the queen it was only
last night at six o'clock
that we were informed by buckingham
palace that the queen had to pull out of
conducting a privy council meeting
which had been penciled in yesterday
evening last night they'd said that
after a full day
on tuesday her majesty uh had accepted
the doctor's advice to rest
which had meant that a privy council
meeting that she was due to be
conducting albeit remotely from balmoral
wasn't able to go ahead i think
yesterday certainly their hand was
really forced to make that announcement
it is
undoubtedly um quite rare for them to
give us any kind of updates when it
comes to to the queen's health
and but in terms of the privy council of
course her new prime minister liz trust
was due to be involved also new members
of the cabinet also during that privy
council meeting should have been sworn
into that important body of advisers to
the monarch it would have appeared in
the court circular and therefore if she
had been unable uh to carry out that
engagement people would have asked
questions so
so yesterday really was the first time
that we we heard these concerns from the
medical household because you have to
remember that there will be medical
people with the queen at the moment no
doubt she is now 96 years old and in in
some ways they are probably just as
important when it comes to advising her
as her principal private secretary we
have to remember we're seeing the
pictures now tuesday was a very busy day
for her majesty the queen and she had
been very clear with all of us and with
her advisors
that no she wasn't able to make that
trip down to london to carry that
important constitutional duty of
appointing a new prime minister but she
still wanted to do that in person and so
the plans had been put in place to make
sure that everyone knew where they
needed to go and so he had her 14th
prime minister boris johnson heading up
to balmoral to tender his resignation
and then we see those pictures there of
the 96 year old queen
welcoming her 15th
prime minister so just to confirm in the
last 10 minutes or so we've had a
statement from buckingham palace
which has said that following further
evaluation this morning the queen's
doctors are concerned for her majesty's
health and have recommended that she
remains under medical supervision the
queen remains comfortable and at
balmoral